So yesterday, after we learned about the death
of Rush Limbaugh, radical right wing radio host
who celebrated the death of Ruth Bader Ginsburg
would celebrate the deaths of AIDS victims that
Rush Limbaugh died yesterday at age 70 of lung
cancer. Donald Trump appeared on Fox News during
the day in advance of his nighttime interviews
on and Newsmax and Fox News. Trump called into
Fox News during the day, sort of to eulogize Rush
Limbaugh. But it was a very strange appearance
and it was self-centered and it was rambling
and it was everything that at this point
we would expect from Donald Trump. So let's
jump right into it. He is succumb to tears.
And I was curious, what did he know was coming?
So I did tell him beforehand because we didn't
have the really the the power of not doing
it. You know, Rush was very sick at the time.
He was at a hospital in Boston. And I
didn't want to do the surprise thing.
I wish I wish I could have done
that. But we really didn't have that.
That that power of doing it because he had
it was a very difficult thing for him to come
into Washington from where he was and he didn't.
And there was questions as to whether or not it
was just a very brave guy who was amazing. And
he came in and it was as he told me, it was the
greatest honor of his life. And everybody in
the room, you know, you're talking about the
Republicans and the Democrats. You had half of
that room went crazy. You remember the evening?
Well, I'm sure it was a very unique moment.
Yes. In our country's history in that sense,
because of the rushes, but half what is absolutely
crazy. The other half that totally dead silent,
but a hundred percent of that room respected Rush.
So complete delusions of grandeur. Of course, it
was a great moment in our country's history when
a radical right wing radio host got a medal from
Donald Trump, basically just a reward for sucking
up to Donald Trump. If that's a notable moment in
American history when Rush Limbaugh degraded the
meaning of the Presidential Medal of Freedom,
well, really, it was Trump who degraded the
meaning of it and the value by awarding it to Rush
Limbaugh. If that is a notable moment in American
history, it says something very sad about the
country. Now, I don't believe that obviously there
are many notable moments in American history.
Trump handing the Medal of Freedom to a
right wing radio host because the radio
hosts supported Trump, not exactly ranking high
in in moments of American history. And of course,
that's why Donald Trump likes Rush Limbaugh,
because Rush supported Donald Trump. And it's
not true. We heard in Trump in Trump's Hannity
interview, which we'll look at tomorrow, Trump
repeated the same line. This line of Democrats
respected Rush Limbaugh. No, they didn't.
Rush Limbaugh did disgusting and depraved things
on air. He attacked women. He attacked gays.
He attacked, you know, just people on the left
in general. He gleefully he was gleeful when
Ruth Bader Ginsburg died, he would celebrate
the deaths of AIDS patients during the 90s. What
Democrats didn't respect Rush
Limbaugh. What on earth is Trump?
Talking about but let's continue, it was a unique
guy and he was a he became a friend of mine, you
know, I didn't know Rush at all. I had essentially
never met Rush. And then when we came down
the escalator, he liked my rather controversial
speech. I made that speech that was a little bit
on the controversial side, and he loved it. And he
was without ever having met him or talked to him
or, you know, had lunch with him and asked if he
was with me right from the beginning. And he liked
what I said. And he agreed with what I said. And
he was just a great gentleman. Great, great man.
And of course, that's what this is all
about. Rush was with Trump to Trump.
That's all that matters. Trump doesn't so
much. Trump often talks about my friends.
He doesn't really have friends. He has yes. Men
and sycophants who he allows to remain around him
for as long as they remain. Yes. Men and
sycophants. That's what Donald Trump has.
And that's how Donald Trump's relationships
work. That's how he evaluates other people.
Trump then uses Rush Limbaugh's death. To repeat
the long debunked lies about the election that
Trump actually won and that Russia believed it.
Paris, what did Rush Limbaugh tell you
after the election of November 3rd?
What were those conversations like?
Well, I thought we won and so do I, by the way. I
think we won by a substantially. And I thought we
won and they thought it was over a ten o'clock,
ten thirty. It was over. And a lot of other
people feel that way too. But Rush felt that way
strongly. And many people do. Many professionals
do. And I don't think that could have happened to
a Democrat. You would have had you would have had
riots going all over the place if that happened
to a Democrat. We don't have the same support
in the at certain levels of the Republican
system, but we have great people as Republicans.
Of course, that was Russia's big thing, calling
Trump up and saying, sir, they stole it from you.
Joe Biden didn't really win. And Trump going
directly into his election fraud talking points.
They're repeating all the same stuff. What a great
coincidence, right, that Rush Limbaugh thought
the exact same thing. So there is Donald Trump's
initial sort of bizarre eulogy of Rush Limbaugh.
He supported me and he agreed the election
was stolen. So he was great. Well said, sir.
Really nicely done. And tomorrow we're going
to look at Donald Trump's interview with Sean
Hannity, where he actually it's not like urgent.
So I don't feel the need to get to it today. We
don't have time. But tomorrow I do want to look
into it because there's some interesting stuff
about 2024, some interesting anecdote.
So tomorrow night we will look, ah,
tomorrow on tomorrow's podcast.
Rather, we will look at last
night's interview that Donald Trump did with
Sean Hannity. In the meantime, we'll have to
leave it there for today, much to the dismay, but
also pleasure of different people in our audience